[Music]
Boston is as American as a guest it's
the birthplace of the revolution and
from its earliest days a home for
immigrants but this is another story
about the Irish or Italian this story
was about Mysterium a culture has
survived the Millennium a lot of people
don't know it a lot of people have never
had a book on when Arabs have given this
world everything as the civil war in
Syria continues many refugees have fled
their homeland and come or attempted to
come to the u.s. they've been otherwise
discriminated against called terrorists
and banned from coming to America we
don't want them here but what you might
not know about this immigrant group
while watching the news is that Syrians
have a long history of coming to the
United States I know this because I'm
Syrian my name is omar and my parents
immigrated from syria to boston in the
80s so in telling the story of syrians
in america i'm in a way telling my own
story and to do that i have to go back
home to Boston it turns out that my home
town was historically one of the most
popular places for Syrians to come to
starting in the 1890s by the way back
then the term Syrian meant anyone coming
from present-day Syria Lebanon Israel
Palestine and Jordan anyway I wanted to
hear about the old Syrian neighborhood
in Boston so I tracked down one of its
last surviving residence Olivia away
Shack there were record shops across the
houses the old lady's like my
grandmother my dad there that would sit
on the stoop and I would smoke to
oriented it was a generation into itself
that was all their traditions all their
customs this was their language they
draw everything here Olivia's father
immigrated from Syria in 1904 and her
mother in 1912 she spent her childhood
in this neighborhood known as Syrian
town or a little Syria which was
situated right next to Chinatown the
main main area was hot route straight
and parallel so that was tired
parallel to that was Harrison Avenue
Syrians came to Boston looking for work
and later religious and political
freedom because Boston was one of the
nation's largest manufacturing centers
many Syrians especially women worked in
textile factories which were built along
Harrison Avenue a lot of factories that
our people worked in stitches now my
mother is a young woman she made samples
my father had a coffee shop they would
play cards and have Turkish coffee and
it was to slide it was enjoyment for
them and that once again
it kept everybody together this
neighborhood was the center of German
culture and community in New England
back then they had everything they had
all of they had done squash that was
preserved and sent from from Syria they
had great leaders that would grind that
woman big big big wooden dowels anything
that you can imagine was imported
because it wasn't made in this country
Olivia's family and the majority of
Syrian immigrants during this time were
Christian but just ten miles south of
Syrian town in Quincy Massachusetts a
small community of Syrian Muslims was
driving I met up with Marilyn Johnson
who teaches about immigration at Boston
College to learn more many of them were
shipyard workers who worked in the fore
River shipyard and so you had a small
Muslim ship building Syrian community
there Marilyn told me about how
adjusting to new life for these
immigrants through the Boston area was
not easy for starters not everyone
wanted them there were a lot of people
were not very happy about it these were
seen as illiterate unskilled undesirable
immigrants then there was a question of
whether or not they were white you had
to be white in order to become
naturalized so if you weren't considered
white then you weren't able to become a
citizen
and Syrians actually fought for years in
the courts the claim that they were
white in order to get citizenship and in
1915 they won in the words of the judge
on the case the generally received
opinion is that the inhabitants of a
portion of Asia including Syria are to
be classed as white persons aside from
Boston New York and Detroit were also
major centers of securing immigration in
these cities you can find Arabic
restaurants and grocery stores
import-export business churches Arabic
language newspapers and magazines and of
course street peddlers peddling was a
well-known occupation among among
Syrians both men and women and often it
was the occupation you might do when you
first got here even if you didn't know
English that well in 1924 the
Immigration Act introduced strict quotas
on immigrants especially those from
Southern and Eastern Europe like
Italians and Eastern European Jews
between the 1920s and the 1960s this is
the restriction era so very few Syrians
enter the country during those years the
quota was probably a hundred or under
for the entire country at the end of
World War two family start to move out
of the crowded downtown Boston area and
into the suburbs for Syrians this lent a
mass migration out of Syrian town and
into nearby West Roxbury and then in the
1960s what was left of Syrian town of
Boston was almost entirely dismantled by
an urban renewal
the extension of the Mass Pike freeway I
came on one day from school and there
was a notice on the door that we had a
vacate
we had no choice so we had a move it
ruined our life and there was no summon
substance joy Olivia's home was
demolished for a freeway down the street
a massive apartment building replaced
the southern part of the neighborhood
what was once textile factories is now
Tufts Medical Center and only the
original neighboring Chinatown were
means any physical sign of all was once
tearing town in Boston is gone but this
is not to say that Syrians are gone
whether you're Christian or Muslim it's
via it's who we are it's the thread of
our fabric it's a tapestry that made us
who we are
every time loving caring devoted and it
kind of scented and you want to use that
is the Syrian people no matter how you
cut it
Syrians have been coming to the United
States since the early 1870s for better
opportunities so we've been here a
minute we just heard from an early
descendent of Syrians to the Boston area
and in the next video we'll explore why
my hearing parents chose to leave Syria
and how our Syrian family also became
American